[Musica]
Lo sapete che proprio nell'età
adolescenziale il nostro cervello
possiede enormi potenzialità la
plasticità che hanno appunto gli
adolescenti è quella capacità di
imparare e di essere creativi e ai
massimi livelli la creatività è quella
dote di percepire e recepire
informazioni esterne e trasformarle in
idee nuove ed innovative
Ti ho girato a letto non avendo fatto
nulla di nuovo rispetto a ieri oggi è
stato sprecato dice Bill Gates questo è
proprio quello di cui ha bisogno Oggi
giorno la nostra società per risolvere
gli innumerevoli problemi di cui siamo
circondati
abbiamo bisogno di regalare ai giovani
terreni fertili sui quali poter
costruire nuove idee e aiutare loro a
trovare il proprio percorso di vita
Eppure quando io ero adolescente e
Frequentavo la scuola secondaria L'unica
cosa che veniva chiesta a me e ai miei
compagni di corso era quella di
immagazzinare informazioni e restituirle
secondo un linguaggio scritto ho parlato
Insomma eravamo visti come una sorta di
database pronti a restituire
informazioni ogni qualvolta ci venisse
richiesto di farlo e quello enorme
capacità di associare quelle
informazioni comporle
giocarci per dare vita idee e ha
pensieri nuovi e cosiddetto pensiero
critico veniva perlopiù represso ed è
così che mi sono sentita negli anni
della scuola secondaria depressa come se
qualcosa all'interno di me fosse pronta
ad esplodere Boom
Eppure ci tengo a specificare che ho
vissuto gli anni della scuola in maniera
di tutto Serena in armonia con i miei
docenti e con i miei compagni di classe
è vero anche una studentessa abbastanza
discreta ma il l'ambiente all'interno
del quale mi trovavo non mi permetteva
di esprimere appieno quel potenziale
ma poi effettivamente ma che cos'è
questo potenziale Al termine delle
superiori ho capito che era finalmente
arrivato il momento di scoprire che
cos'è questo potenziare e di poterlo
esprimere ma per arrivare all'obiettivo
e alla mia missione pensavo che fosse
fondamentale riuscire ad individuare è
giusto percorso universitario e per un
po'
in banca un po' di cose che credevo di
non saper fare è un po' per intuito ho
scelto di frequentare l'università di
design perché credevo di avere delle
buone idee e l'unica cosa che sapevo
dell'ambito del design e che quella che
ti permette appunto di sviluppare delle
idee attraverso un processo creativo
uno dei fulcri principali che si studia
in tutti e le facoltà di design e il
metodo del design thinking E cos'è il
metodo dei sentimenti non è un approccio
che ci permette di risolvere problemi
complessi di sciogliere i nostri
problemi complessi e di arrivare ad una
soluzione quindi di sviluppare dei
progetti
del mai capitato di preparare la ricetta
tramandata da vostra nonna o da vostra
madre con i soli in pochi ingredienti
che avete presenti in frigo Ecco il
design thinking è proprio quel metodo
quella ricetta che vi permette di che si
adatta ai pochi ingredienti che avete a
vostra disposizione
questa metodologia viene utilizzata
dalle aziende per realizzare servizi e
prodotti io lavoro nell'ambito della
Digital Innovation e anche noi
utilizziamo il metodo del design
thinking per realizzare
quali piattaforme applicazioni e
software
Dunque tornando a quella che era la mia
missione il mio obiettivo era quello di
realizzare individuare il mio percorso
per realizzarmi dal punto di vista
professionale ma cercare anche di
divenire una persona utile alla società
E allora cosa ha deciso di fare ho
scelto di sperimentare il metodo del
design thinking su me stessa metodo Che
fantastica parola che metodo deriva dal
greco methodos metà odos che
letteralmente significa via per giungere
ad un luogo via per arrivare ad uno
scopo cioè strada attraverso cui andare
oltre e andare oltre le mie paure le mie
insicurezze Per un futuro era proprio
quello di cui io avevo esattamente
bisogno
E allora Che cos'è il metodo delle senti
Innanzitutto bisogna dire che si divide
in cinque fasi fase 1 Individua il
problema empatizza con te stesso
dobbiamo essere in grado di parlare con
sé stessi per capire effettivamente
Quali sono le nostre preoccupazioni e
qual è l'obiettivo che vogliamo
raggiungere il mio problema era proprio
il fatto che io non riuscisse ad
individuare l'obiettivo da raggiungere e
come avrei potuto scegliere allora la
strada da intraprendere poi se due
ricerca
ricercare in realtà comprende in sé una
serie di azioni investigare indagare
ascoltare osservare dovete essere in
grado di osservare voi stessi
dall'esterno per capire quali sono le
vostre competenze e peculiarità e dovete
anche essere in grado di capire quali
sono gli ambiti lavorativi in cui queste
competenze
essere sfruttate ai massimi livelli
Bisognerebbe un po' comportarsi come se
noi fossimo dei tecnici in un
laboratorio che sono lì ad osservare i
microrganismi che mutano che cambiano in
base ai diversi contesti ambientali e
all'interno del quale vengono inseriti
in questo caso noi rappresentiamo sia il
tecnico sia il microrganismo da
osservare
un'altra azione importante in questa
fase è il dialogo il dialogo interiore
verso se stessi e gli alogo verso gli
altri dobbiamo essere curiosi chiediamo
più cose possibili
terza fase definizione dobbiamo
effettivamente capire i contesti i
settori all'interno dei quali le nostre
competenze possono essere più utili ma
dobbiamo sempre valutare tutte le
opzioni che si presentano in questa fase
il campo d'azione all'interno del quale
andremo a compiere le prossime mosse
comincia a restringersi i bordi della
strada si fanno finalmente più nitidi
Guarda fase la messa in pratica io la
chiamo la fase del coraggio buttati
sperimenta le tue competenze
arrivata ad un certo punto del mio
percorso lavorativo
io ho abbandonato il lavoro anche il
lavoro all'interno del quale avrei
ancora avuto possibilità di fare
carriera Ho quindi lasciato la mia
comfort zone perché avevo finalmente
capito quello che non mi piaceva fare ma
ero così vicina dalla Ferrari con
consapevolezza quello che in realtà mi
piaceva fare
stavo frequentando stavo per terminare
un master contemporaneamente lavoravo in
uno studio di architettura
internazionale e nel frattempo ho avuto
la possibilità di dirigere alcuni eventi
all'interno del palinsesto della design
week da prima ho terminato tutti tutti i
progetti anche con un discreto successo
Dopodiché mi sono rimessa subito in
gioco e finalmente ho cominciato il mio
percorso all'interno del mondo del
Digital grazie a questa scelta ea
l'esperienza che ho maturato ho avuto
anche la possibilità di vincere alcuni
alcune competizioni progettuali
nazionali ed internazionali e questa
cosa mi ha dato ancora più motivazione
per individuare è raggiungere
l'obiettivo che finalmente avevo fatto
mio
questo per dirvi cosa date modo a voi
stessi di fare anche esperienze diverse
Perché solo così potrete capire e Cosa
ti piace fare e cosa in cui siete più
portati a fare probabilmente in alcuni
contesti di sentire a disagio
addirittura lasciatemi passare il
termine piccoli perché magari meno
competenti è come un esperienza rispetto
ad altri ma saranno proprio quelle
esperienze a darvi tanta motivazione e a
farvi crescere e arrivano all'ultima
fase potenza il potenziamento Siamo
all'ultimo step adesso finalmente
abbiamo individuato cosa ci piace fare
il settore all'interno del quale
possiamo operare e quindi adesso
dobbiamo semplicemente
fare esperienza
Se noi vogliamo realmente evolvere il
mondo dobbiamo prima evolvere noi stessi
ed è esattamente quello che ho fatto ho
cominciato a stressare sempre di più le
mie competenze frequentando ambienti
stimolanti e collaborando in team di
persone molto più competenti di me
quello che io voglio dire con questo
discorso non sono qui a vendere il
metodo del design thinking materialmente
voi giovani Volete dare un apporto
positivo alla società Volete dare un
impatto innovativo la società Il
progetto primario sul quale dovete
investire il vostro tempo con
determinazione ed impegno Siete proprio
voi stessi Al di là delle opportunità
che ti vengono offerte dalla scuola dal
mondo del lavoro dalla realtà e dagli
altri enti il progetto sul quale dovete
investire siete voi stessi Al di là
delle collaborazioni all'interno di
aziende e di studi professionali ho
avuto anche l'opportunità di far parte
di collaborare con associazioni e
Community all'interno dei quali ho avuto
la preziosa e ripeto preziosa occasione
di interagire con ragazzi molto più
giovani di me giovani intraprendenti
pieni di idee pronte a divenire il
prossimo il on Mask
Però anche loro come me e me cosa hanno
in passato ancora oggi sentono quel
senso di depressione Manuel forte
desiderio di volersi sperimentare e di
voler lanciare al mondo il proprio
potenziale magari maniera anche più
dotata
io dico ai giovani questi giovani che
oggi ci sono in Italia tante possibilità
contesti lavorativi e formativi per così
dire
anticonvenzionali e lo dico con un
sorriso sulle labbra anticonvenzionali
opportunità al all'interno delle quali
potersi sperimentare Quindi facciamo un
atto di coraggio e Mettiamoci in gioco
Allora vi dico se non ancora l'avete
fatto fermatevi e trovate il metodo per
valorizzare il vostro potenziale
design Yourself siate il vostro progetto
più importante è la società ve ne sarà
riconoscente
[Applauso]